a newborn calf weighs 40 kilograms each
week its weight increases by 5
let w be the weight in kilograms of the
calf after t weeks is w a linear
function or an exponential function so
if w were a linear function that means
that every week that goes by the weight
would increase by the same amount so
let's say that every week that went by
the weight increases or really they're
talking about mass year the mass
increased by five kilograms then we'd be
dealing with a linear function but
they're not saying that the weight
increases by five kilograms they're
saying by five percent so after one week
it'll be 1.05
times 40 kilograms after another week
it'll be 1.05 times that it'll be five
percent more after the next week it'll
be 1.05 times that so really what if we
really think about this function it's
going to be 40 kilograms times 1.05 to
the t power we're compounding by five
percent every time we're increasing by a
factor of one point zero five or another
way of thinking by by a factor of a
hundred five percent
every week so because we have that that
growth by a factor not just by a
constant number that tells it tells us
that this is going to be an exponential
function so let's see which of these
choices describe that
this function is linear no we don't have
to even read that this function is
linear nope this function is exponential
because w increases by a factor of 5
each time t increases by one no that's
not right we're increasing by five
percent increasing by five percent means
you're 1.05 times as big as you were
before increasing so it's really this
function is exponential because w
increases by a factor of
1.05 each time t increases by one that
right over there
is the right answer let's try one more
of these
determine whether the quantity described
is changing in a linear fashion or an
exponential fashion
fidel has a rare coin worth 550 dollars
each year the coins value increases by
well this is just like the last example
we saw we're increasing every year that
goes by as we increase by a factor of
1.1 if we grow by 10
that's increasing by a factor of 110 or
1.1 so this is definitely exponential if
it was increasing 10 dollars per year
then it would be linear but here we're
increasing by a percentage
your uncle
bought a car for 130 000 mexican pesos
each year the value of the car decreases
by 10 000 pesos so here we're not we're
not multiplying by a factor we're
decreasing by a fixed amount year one
year goes by we're at 120 000. two years
goes by we're at 110 000. so this is
definitely a linear this can be
described as by a linear model
the number of wild hogs in arkansas
increases by a factor of three every
five years so a factor of three every
five years they're not saying it
increases by three hogs every five years
we're multiplying by three every five
years so this is definitely
this one right over here is going to be
exponential
and then finally you work as a waiter at
a restaurant you earn fifty dollars in
tips every day you work well this is
super this you know this should jump out
as as very linear every day you work
another fifty dollars work one day fifty
dollars two days a hundred dollars so
forth and so on they're not saying that
you earn 50 times as much as the day
before they're not saying that you're 50
percent more they're saying that you're
increasing by a fixed quantity so this
is going to be a linear model